well we can bring you some breaking news
now on the future of the retail group
mccolls our city editor mark clyman
broke the news yesterday that morrisons
had tabled a last-gasp bid for mccolls
paving the way for a battle with its
rival eg group whose owners also own
asda and mark joins me now on the phone
with an update on this story mark what's
the latest
yes you know i understand that after a
weekend of frantic negotiations
morrisons has emerged victorious from
the battle for mc for control of
mccoll's retail group
and that comes with a pledge to retain
all 1100 stores and 16
000 jobs now i understand that pwc the
advisor to mccoll's lenders and the
administrator in waiting notified both
morrisons and eg group this morning of
the outcome of this late night auction
last night
one of the key points herein is that
mccoll's pension obligations which have
become a point of contention
over the last few days will be honored
in full by morrisons which is also
agreed to repay
mccoll's bank lenders immediately in
cash uh notwithstanding that this deal
will be structured as a prepack
administration making this the uk's
biggest high street insolvency since
edinburgh woolen mill group in 2020 but
given the precarious state of mccall's
finances in recent times in this deal
with morrisons which i expect to be
announced by pwc
later on today has to be considered a
positive outcome in the circumstances
all right mark thanks for that